[Music]
but I want talk about atheism because
it's been one of why it's so boring just
a couple of people wrong in a room being
very angry on the internet so you don't
you almost think that atheists don't
exist there's some no no no lesbians
don't exist arari unfortunately there
are four see there are a so there are a
you acknowledge that there are P there
are lots of wrong people in the world
you know and one of the wrong kinds of
wrong people they're atheists now the
thing I find about AC I don't really
care if somebody believes in God or not
I hope they do I wish they did because I
know quite a nice if they join me up
there you know in 40 50 years but I've
got a first-class ticket she loves me
I'm very confident I reason like the
reason I have a go a theist is because
it's fun because they're so thin-skinned
they're like come they're like
libertarians or they're like cyclists or
Liberal Democrats in the UK or you know
any other sort of war feminists in fact
you know they're so easy to wind up I
mean you know how many atheists is it
take to change a light bulb before
you've even given the punchline people
are furious and there's a reddit thread
about it and they're just so much fun
and why would you be going after the
people that it's easy to go after I mean
every poll shows these these people have
some of the most celebrated public
intellectuals on this side Richard
Dawkins the late Christopher Christopher
Hitchens these people have huge public
intellectuals on their side military
militant atheism if you like atheism is
the trendiest thing in the world every
journalist is an atheist everybody in
the media is an atheist no you don't
never gonna get somebody laugh at you or
look at you weirdly for announcing
you're an atheist you announce you're a
Christian or a Muslim or Eve
you know all sorts of bad things happen
to you right nobody nobody looks at you
funny except me I probably any person if
you announce that you're an atheist
because you know this is this is the
this is a privileged group in society
that I find it funny to take the mickey
out of because they are so touchy this
is interesting because so when you were
talking about gamergate part of what you
liked is that there was this groundswell
coming up from the bottom fighting this
authoritarian and i think religious
people of that again
now but but I don't think we're there
yet I get that angle and this is what
all my friends on the right say that the
religious now are the ones being
oppressed and Christians are being I
wouldn't go supposed to say I wouldn't
goes for us to say oppressed saying it's
basically crazy is is wrong I wouldn't
go as far as to say Christians are an
oppressed class in this country cuz I
don't think there are many oppressed
classes in this country I would only
think maybe black people still that's
probably the only one in this country I
don't think they're depressed class but
I do think I've been very ashamed of my
fellow my fellow homosexuals in the way
that they have behaved toward Christians
and some of the media circuses that
happened recently I have I can go with
you and that deeply deeply horrified to
watch gay people treat Christians as
gays were treated for barely two decades
ago well so I do think that same value
that but I do I have noticed you know I
did a David Webb who's gonna be a guest
on our show in a couple weeks from Fox
News and on Sirius XM I was on his show
when gay marriage was was being passed
by the Supreme Court law was being
struck down today shame yeah we'll get
to that too in a second but what he said
to me just literally I think it was the
first day it was the day that it
happened was that we should really
already start being we should start
policing the gays to make sure we don't
start oppressing Christian but isn't
that a little don't we have to give it a
little time don't we have to let gays
have a little time to work with to be
bullies no no no no we don't need to
give gay people any time to be bullies
they have shown and this is it this is
what you this is something that I always
find interesting about people how they
behave when they enter the corridors of
power how people behave when they are
granted these status that they have
asked for for so long
when gays are finally not just equal
society but held up as models of
Paragons of virtue I mean you read you
read Gore Cora BuzzFeed you would think
that being gay was some kind of moral
objective but being gay was some was you
know it was better than being straight
in some way you know I'm not gonna say
perhaps discuss it and second I'll show
what I think on that but you know it but
it seems like a weird proposition enough
on the face of it but if you read
BuzzFeed or Vox at all Gawker you'll get
that impression no I don't think gay
people deserve any time to be bullies to
settle into you know their position or
in authority and I think it does gay
people a lot of damage to see these
bitter hysterical nasty
Queens bullying and lecturing and
hectoring ordinary decent law-abiding
people of faith and I thought it was
utterly deplorable when that couple who
staged a renewal of their vows they
didn't even have a wedding but they
staged a renewal of their vows they
already had the wedding solely it seemed
to get a photo opportunity with pizzas
for memories pizza which they tricked
this Christian Christian pizzeria into
catering their thing now set aside the
horror I think most gay people at home
will feel about pizza I know I've told
your cameraman to shoot me from here set
that aside how hollow and bitter what a
terror what an awful kind of human being
you would have to be to turn your
special day so in a day of appreciation
and celebration between you and your
family the people that you love into a
gps you think that you know you've gay
people in many cases turn themselves as
the worst kind of grandstanding bigots
no they do not need time to settle in
they're very much settled it right so
I'm sort of with you on that because I I
do understand that look they purposely
did this for a Christian Baker had they
went to it they got to they got to an
Orthodox Jewish Baker or or a Muslim
Baker and force them to do this the
media wouldn't have nearly the fun that
they had so just wrapping this around
atheism then we're gonna do everything
else we're gonna do is gay for the rest
of this after after this final question
I know it's exhausting position of power
do you think that I don't see atheists
in any position yes there are a couple
cool thought of atheists out there right
positions of power now it's about but
what do you think social cachet but so
what do you think that the main the
average atheist in which an atheist is
only brought together by the lack of the
belief in a deity oh no I mean they're
brought together by you know sort of
wispy facial hair terrible spectacles of
long ginger ponytails terrible terrible
thin-skinned natural sort of demeanor
you know to hair-trigger temper these
are the primary characteristics of an
atheist socks and sandals Tara those
terrible cheap chinos you know all that
kind of
if that's what you want to response you
then go right ahead
but you know Kath Catholics all the best
outfits you know rich older men in
dresses what's not to love
we know if you want if you're if you're
now a sense of style and you become a
Muslim or or or a Catholic um no I mean
look a theists are it is not just
acceptable but it is the norm in any
metropolitan city in Europe or in
America to be an atheist it is normal to
be an atheist people look at you weird
if you're not right so what's the
problem with that it's funny to say the
personality you just want to make fun of
them even I enjoy making fun of them I
enjoy making fun out of everybody I feel
making fun out of you I enjoy making fun
myself I make fun out of myself all day
on my Twitter feed that's what that's
what provocateurs do all right well I
can accept that I will grant you that
but I won that one that little section
but I don't well you can have one hour
[Music]